i must confess
i still believe
hit me baby one more time
hey anwar
what you doing
how's it going mike so anwar are you
coming over to what man come on
mike i told you i'm busy all week
brother i i really can't bro you can
you can please don't do this right now
you can you can wow you can't give me a
good reason why you can't come i'm
actually cooking dinner tonight so i
i'll make you a sandwich you never
believe it pita bread and all i'm not
hungry right now i honestly i don't have
time for that might come over i really
don't have time to come over now
please
the whole thing
all of it i'm a cheese master it's a
sandwich like you never had taste before
in your life sandwich
it's a little too much cheese don't you
think so listen don't disrespect my
secret recipe it's been my family for
2000 years they survive slavery
see not all that bad pretty fine
sandwich isn't it
it's delicious i agree
real goat cheese from the kazakhstan
mountain triple g
goat cheese
you're from kazakhstan aren't you no
oh well really good stuff and you better
finish that real fast the whole thing
you want me to finish the whole
thing
suck it down buddy can i take it to go
no i can't do this anymore i got to go
home now [ __ ] that we playing call of
duty man we're on the duty right now i
can't my wife
oh man you got me of course you know
we're gonna get you
maybe you try again have better luck
yeah okay one more time
i was good in the ring but i'm a god
here
daddy daddy daddy daddy daddy
yeah okay did rome take over egypt
wasn't all the time in the room now done
the egypt now
okay we can't conquer nobody's country
no more
[Music]
little girl distracted me she was
talking to me how you gonna claim some
kind of win like that it was just one
kill
it was just one kid
get the [ __ ] out of here
you